el presidente piñera no participó ni
tenía conocimiento del proceso de venta
del proyecto de minera dominga con estas
palabras categóricas se manifiesta un
comunicado de prensa de presidencia
chilena que señala que el presidente del
gobierno sebastián piñera no ha
participado en los últimos 12 años en
ningún tipo de sus negocios porque los
tienen sido comicios ciegos esto es la
forma en la que salen al paso en el
llamado escándalo de los papeles de
pandora que establece que piñera vendió
las acciones del proyecto de minería
domingo a uno de sus mejores amigos
carlos délano y que lo hizo en un pago a
tres cuotas la última del cuyas cuotas
estaría vinculada a derecho de que no
hubiera un cambio regulatorio que
impidiera que el proyecto se instalará
en esta zona por ser declarada de
protección ambiental el proyecto incluye
también un puerto esta zona no ha sido
declarada de protección ambiental ni en
el primero ni en el segundo mandato de
sebastián piñera a pesar de ser un
hotspot de biodiversidad muy importante
para aves marinas como ballenas
pingüinos
delfines y otros los hechos fueron
profundamente investigados por los
tribunales de justicia chilenos que
determinaron que no existían delitos en
una decisión que fue ratificada después
por la corte de apelaciones y por el
tribunal supremo- dice también este
comunicado sin embargo muchos argumentan
que en ese momento no se conocía los
detalles que fueron desvelados hoy
especialmente la cláusula que tiene que
ver con el pago de la última cuota
vinculado a cambios regulatorios que
tienen la potestad de decidir el
gobierno y también el hecho que el
acuerdo se firmó en las situadas y
vírgenes británicas